من قريه برقه ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
ليث جعار ليث ما الذي تشاهده ونحن نرى في
افق الصوره خلفك اليات للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تتمركز عند مدخل
القريه نعم
بالفعل 12 ساعه على العمليه العسكريه ولا
يزال الاحتلال يتواجد في داخل قريه برقه
الى الشمال الغربي من محافظه نابلس وسط
مداهمات واسعه نفذها الاحتلال في داخل
المنازل هنا في القريه نرصد في هذه الصوره
تمركز لاليات الاحتلال العسكريه التي تغلق
كافه مداخل بلده برقه وا الاعلان عن ان
برقه نقطه عسكريه مغلقه هذا يعني منع تحرك
المواطنين حتى داخل البلده ايه فرض حصار
واسع على البلده اغلاق لكافه المداخل من
كافه المحاور وحتى هذه اللحظه وبعد 12
ساعه نتحدث عن اعتقال على الاقل 20
فلسطينيا من داخل هذه القريه فيما لا يزال
الاحتلال يقوم باعمال التحقيق الميداني مع
عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين اكثر من 70
فلسطينيا تم التحقيق معهم ميدانيا داخل
البلده اعتقل الاحتلال 20 منهم حمله
مداهمات واسعه لعدد من المنازل تدمير
وتخريب ل ممتلكات المواطنين هذا يعني لا
يزال مستمر منذ الساعه الحاد ليلا وحتى
هذه اللحظه نرصد التواجد لاليات الاحتلال
العسكريه والجنود الاحتلال الذين يغلقون
الطرق امام الفلسطينيين منع المرور من اي
طريق وصولا الى قريه برقه يذكر ان المدخل
الرئيسي للقريه مغلق منذ اشهر وهو المدخل
الغربي للقريه والواصل الى مستوطنه او
البؤره الاستيطانيه التي ينوي الاحتلال
اقامتها وهي مستوطنه حومش الى الشمال من
القريه والجاثيه على اراضي القريه
الاحتلال حتى هذه اللحظه يسيطر على عدد من
المنازل اقامه نقاط عسكريه في داخل القريه
وينتشر
و نازل يغلق الطرقات ويمنع تحرك
الفلسطينيين اي فلسطيني يحاول خروج من
المنزل يقوم الاحتلال
ب يعني استجوابه ومحاصرته طيب ليث ما
السياق الذي تاتي فيه هذه العمليات في
برقه ايه الاحتلال حقيقه
يعني ضمن هذه العمليه العسكريه يحاول او
وضع حجه بانه يبحث عن عبوات ناسفه في داخل
القريه يبحث في كل المنازل يقوم بتخريب
ايه المنازل بحثا عن عبوات ناسفه يدعي
انها موجوده في بعض المنازل ويقوم الشبان
الفلسطينيين
بتحضيرها لالقائها على الطريق الواصل الى
مستوطنه الى مستوطنه حومش المقاومه
والجاثيه على اراضي القريه ل يعني
الاعتداء او محاوله استهداف المستوطنين
واليات الاحتلال التي تتحرك باستمرار نح
وهذه البؤره الاستيطانيه هذه هي الحجه
الرئيسيه التي يهدف لها الاحتلال والتي
يحاول الاحتلال او قام الاحتلال من خلالها
باقتحام القريه ومحاصر كافه المنازل
محاولات تفتيش وتدمير لممتلكات
الفلسطينيين بحثا عن عبوات ناسفه نشكرك
جزيل الشكر من قريه برقه مراسل الجزيره
ليث جعار